والنظم الايراني باتى محاصرا في حلقه
مفرغه بحسب تصريحات مسؤولين امريكيين
واجانب جمعتها صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه
الحلقه المفرغه هذه هو بحسب الجارد تدفع
البلاد الى مزيد من العزله الدوليه مهما
حاولت ايران تخلص منها المبعوث الامريكي
الخاص روبرت مالي كان له التصريح الابرز
اذ قال ان واشنطن تركز على قرار تسليح
روسيا في اوكرانيا وقمع احتجاجاتها
الداخليه اكثر من تركيزها على محادثات في
احياء الاتفاق النووي واكدا ان العرض
التالي للتضامن الامريكي مع المحتجين من
المرجح ان ياتي عندما تقدم واشنطن اقتراحا
باستبعاد ايران من لجنه الامم المتحده
المعنيه بوضع المراه في تصويت المقرر يوم
الرابعه عشر من ديسمبر وفي سياق المتصل او
ردت الصحيفه البريطانيه ان دبلوماسيين
اوروبيين يرون ان القياده الايرانيه وصلت
الى نقطه تحول لا رجعه فيها وان النظام
الايرانيه يعيش تحت ضغوطي السبل المثلاث
للتعامل مع الاحتجاجات
مروز صارديه زينه
[موسيقى]